Well we’re all very excited to have you here
But I must warn you, the Garpax has eyes EVERYWHERE
Be careful what you say
and let your game do the talking
Have no doubt,
I’m as healthy as ever AND I shoot threes now
There’s no reason we can’t form a superteam
Is that...is that  Dwyane Wade?
—here in Chicago—
Oh Seven Hells
It is. It is you!
Who is that?
Someone you know?
Mario Chalmers
We used to play together in Miami
Oh great, here we go
Hello Rio
Nooooo
You’re on the Bulls now?
Oh that’s so WEIRD
We was on a superteam together
“The Big Four!”
‘Member those days, Dwyane?
...no?
But I can’t blame you for leaving really
Twilight-a your career...
bad knees, bad shoulders...
maybe you can scrape together one last playoff run with...
sorry what’s your name?
Jimmy Butler
Oh
You DO look a lot like Michael Jordan
Well it’s all very exciting
We must be going now, I’m afraid
Oh. Alright, um, well,
if you need a point guard
or whatever...
just, send me a raven, yeah?
We have Rondo
Oh well,
you never know with him
He’s a bit...
(crazy whistle)
You’ll definitely need a veteran backup, no?
We have plenty of depth but we’ll keep you in mind
Cause...you know,
we could be a superteam again!
Bye Rio!
YOU CAN YELL AT ME ALL YOU LIKE
I DON’T MIND!
Alright, well...
guess I’ll head to Cleveland
Gadzooks!
Come in, come in!
I came to say hello and welcome you to Houston
Ah! Why thank you!
And you must be the new scouting apprentice!
I’ve been expecting you
Uh...I’m your starting shooting guard...
James Harden?
All Realm shooting guard?
James... James... you say...
one moment please!
Aha!
James Harden!
The point guard. Forgive me.
Shooting guard--
I’ve been studying your game...
it’s marvelous. Brilliant really!
Oh, that’s very kind of you to say...
So you...have a lot of books, I see
This whole shelf is... inbound plays?
Ah yes...
baseline, sideline...
I also keep iso plays in there somewhere
for no good reason really
And this shelf here,
all books on the art of the pass
Wow!
Over there, that's tempo plays, pick and rolls...
you name it!
Feel free to borrow them as you please, by the way
Wow
I bet you need whole new library just for all
defensive plays
Hmm?
Defense...like...you know
when the other team has the ball?
...And they try to...you know...score...
on... us?
Oh no no no. None of that here
It’s a waste of energy and it’s no fun
I say
half the defense...
double the offense!